Human Rights Watch says a Saudi teen
who's fleeing abuse has barricaded
herself in a hotel room at a Bangkok
Airport to avoid deportation Thai
authorities say Rohith muhammad al
kanoon would be sent back to kuwait
today where her family is located but al
kanoon says she holds a visa for
Australia and plans to seek asylum there
the 18 year old claims her passport was
seized by a Saudi official during a
layover in Bangkok okay let's go
straight to Bangkok down DWS Florian
knows covering this story for us good
morning Florian
we heard from a raha there and and she's
talking about why she has being held in
in Thailand and wants to seek asylum in
Australia why is that being denied to
her right now
well the situation is not 100% clear
right now what I can tell you is that
she was supposed to have a layover here
in Bangkok and then travel on to
Australia where she had planned to claim
or seek for asylum there's conflicting
information on how long this layover
here in Bangkok was supposed to be there
are reports saying that she had actually
planned to stay for a few days here in
Bangkok now in that case obviously she
would have needed a visa to enter
Thailand which apparently she does not
have others are saying no she just
wanted to change planes get on the next
one to Australia and just be in the
transit area in in in Bangkok so right
now apparently there are time' Gration
officials and the saudi officials from
the from the embassy here trying to you
know solve this situation which for
every side is very well difficult okay
at the same time we have Human Rights
Watch calling on Thailand not to deport
rajas let's take a listen to that the
reality is that she should have the
right to seek asylum I don't think that
was her first choice I think she wanted
to go to Australia that was her original
plan but you know in this situation now
she needs
to be provided protection because if she
is sent back she will face very serious
physical harm from her from her
relatives
okay very serious physical harm we hear
there a fluorine
why is she facing violence at home well
so far we only have her word but I think
it's quite credible that she has been
abused at least psychologically that's
what she says but she also claims she
has been abused physically for just
being a modern woman who wants to lead
her life as women in the West basically
so she writes in her Twitter account
that for example just for cutting her
hair short she had basically she was put
under house arrest for six months she
wasn't allowed to to leave her room she
has renounced Islam and apparently that
is something that is very very severe
this is why she said she had to leave to
flee her family to flee Saudi Arabia and
seek protection somewhere else
okay this case is of course getting as a
result of all of this a lot of
international attention and raha is
getting a lot of personal support as
well yes definitely I mean this story is
going wild on social media for once I
guess because the infamous case of
journalists Jamarcus Oggy from Saudi
Arabia who was murdered in Turkey by
Saudi officials apparently this has put
Saudi Arabia under scrutiny and so
everyone has been reminded that the
situation in terms of human rights is
very very difficult in Saudi Arabia but
it's also Thailand that is in the public
eye right now and Thailand has a history
indeed of sending back refugees seekers
to their respective countries even to
authoritarian regimes just in October we
have seen the case of Bahraini national
who was on his honeymoon here in
in Bangkok in Thailand and so Thai
authorities have seized him have put him
in detention because the rain actually
demanded that he would be sent back to
Bahrain so this situation is also quite
unclear so we have to wait and see what
the fate of this Saudi woman will be
there are many other flights not direct
flights but layover flights to Kuwait to
Saudi Arabia so there are still plenty
of opportunity to send her back okay
we'll have more from Florian ish for us
later today on this story of fluorine
for now thank you very much okay let's
get more on this story now from Phil
Robertson from Human Rights Watch he's
been helping coordinate efforts to
prevent Rojas deportation Phil thanks so
much for being with us this morning why
is Human Rights Watch calling for Rajas
deportation to be halted well she has
suffered psychological and physical
abuse before she arrived in Saudi Arabia
she is quite fearful for his life her
life if she is sent back we're calling
for the Thai government to permit the UN
refugee agency the UNHCR to have access
to her and to allow them to do a status
determination on or whether she needs to
receive refugee protection and if she
does she should receive that and
Thailand should abide by that okay you
personally have been in touch with Rajas
how she holding up right now she's very
frightened she's very tired
she has been awake for four days and she
is still determined to fight but she
doesn't know what's gonna happen next
she has barricaded herself in a hotel
room at the airport she is saying that
she will only talk to UNHCR and we
continue to press the Thai government to
allow UNHCR to have access to her and
and to offer her the kind of protection
that she needs because if she sent back
we have very very serious fears that she
would suffer great harm
okay even know talking to the Thai
government to make sure Rolf gets the
protection that she needs she wants to
seek asylum in Australia she says she
has a visa to go there why then is the
Thai government not letting her simply
move on well that's an excellent
question
what happened was when she arrived from
Kuwait in Thailand she was met at the at
the gangway of of the plane coming off
the plane at by a Thai official from the
Saudi embassy who seized her passport
and since then that passport has been
kept from her you know and they're now
saying that they're going to send her
back to Kuwait
they say that she applied for and failed
to get a visa on arrival in Thailand but
in fact she didn't want to go to
Thailand she was a GU plane to go to
Australia
she had a tourist visa for Australia and
she should have been permitted to go
there with no interference Phil
Robertson coordinating right now the
efforts to prevent Rajas deportation
from Thailand thanks very much for being
with us today
you